during the bear Market we see the price
of Bitcoin fall drastically and that's
exactly what's happened since November
of last year the price has fallen by 70
this puts immense pressure on the
Bitcoin miners especially the publicly
traded ones before we talk about the
current situation let's take a step back
and remember that last year was a banner
year for many of these publicly traded
miners they use debt and other types of
financing to fuel impressive growth but
now as bitcoin's price has fallen we've
seen the hash rate continue to explode
upwards which means price is down that's
the financial reward but competition is
up that's the hash rate and so naturally
as we watch these people and these
companies under immense pressure they're
having to make hard decisions if we use
core scientific which Dylan LeClaire
from Bitcoin magazine so eloquently
pointed out they are the quintessential
example at the moment in a filing with
the SEC earlier this week they stated
the following as a result management has
been actively taking steps to decrease
monthly costs delay construction
expenses reduce And Delay Capital
expenditures and increase hosting
revenues in addition the board has
decided that the company will not make
payments coming due in late October and
early November 2022 with respect to
several of its equipment and other
financings now the reason why this is a
big deal is because core scientific is
obviously Under Pressure their stock
price is down a lot and the price of
Bitcoin is not helping but they also had
more than 1 000 Bitcoin that was sitting
on their balance sheet later in that
same filing they stated that they've
actually sold most of that Bitcoin in
the filing they say as of October 26th
the company only holds 24 Bitcoin and
approximately 26 million dollars in cash
that compares to over a thousand Bitcoin
and approximately 29 million dollars in
cash as of September 30th of this year
these Bitcoin miners are facing
incredible pressure and many of them are
fighting for their life right now the
reason why core scientific is such a
great example is that they're the
largest publicly traded Miner by hash
rate and so even the big guys they're in
trouble as well now there will be plenty
of people dunking on course scientific
over the coming weeks and months I don't
think that that's fair the real reality
is that building businesses is tough and
in Bear markets that becomes more
complex and much harder ultimately these
teams are gonna have to decide can they
give financing in the debt and Equity
markets or will they have to pursue some
sort of other strategy it's rough out
there right now and the publicly traded
miners are not safe we are watching in
real time the pain of a bear market and
ultimately I'm hoping as should you that
these companies all come out on the
other side healthier stronger and ready
to thrive in the next bull market